i'm here the khan academy exercise
called find one on the number line and
they're asking us to do exactly that it
says move the dot to one on the number
line and it's a little interactive dot
that i could move around and so let's
think about how i would do it and i
always encourage you pause this video
and see at least how you think about
doing it or or put your finger on the
screen where you think one is and then
we'll work through it together
all right so they've told us where zero
is and they've told us where seven
fourths is
so one thing i could do is i could say
well how many of these equal spaces does
it take me to get from zero to seven
fourths so let's see it's 1 2 3 4 five
six seven
so if it takes seven equal spaces to get
to seven fourths that means that each of
these spaces is one-fourth because then
it would be one-fourth two-fourths
three-fourths
four-fourths
five-fourths six-fourths and
seven-fourths all right we're making
some good progress so where would one be
well one would be four-fourths
so we would go
one-fourth two-fourths three-fourths and
then four-fourths so that's where one is
so the important thing to realize is the
only way we knew that each of these each
of these gaps or each of these spaces
from one hash to the next the way that
we knew that each of those is a fourth
is by saying hey look seven of those
equal spaces get us to seven fourths so
each of these must be a fourth so four
of those four fourths would be equal to
one
let's do another example
so here we said we're told to move the
dot to one on the number line so put
your finger on on where that would be on
the screen pause the video and do that
all right in some ways this is a little
bit easier because they told us that
going from zero to the next the next
little cross or hash i guess you could
say whatever you want to call these
things
is one-sixth so what is one well one or
one whole is six-sixths so this is
one-sixth
two-sixths
three-sixths
four-sixths
5 6
and then 6 6
so there we go that is where one is on
this number line